est ce que quand tu as un responsable
politique ou une institution d'ailleurs
a été mêlé à des affaires même si la
justice dit qu'il faut s'arrêter là le
mal est fait en quelque sorte la trace
la réputation et durablement entacher
pour une institution ou une personne
il ya le temps de la justice et puis il
ya le temps de la prise de décision par
les français et finalement si on regarde
la sphère ferrand avec ce qu'ils disent
sur les réseaux sociaux on s'aperçoit
que c'est celui qui est probablement le
plus critique et de l'ensemble des
députés de la république en marche c'est
c'est principalement parce que il était
le chantre de violement d'une certaine
moralité et que forcément il est il est
tombé entre le 22 et le 29 mai suite à
la révélation du canard sur ses sauts
montage financier